what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves I my sincere hope is that if
you see in you what I see in you you'll
be able to change the planet so to help
you on your journey today I'm going to
talk about the seven ways to discover
your strengths and weaknesses so
question I get asked a lot by different
entrepreneurs trying to figure out their
path figure out where they're gonna go
was what am I good at what am i strong
at what am i weak at and how do I use
that to build a successful business so
today I'm gonna share with you my seven
tips on how to discover your strengths
and weaknesses tip number one is just
think about what do you have the most
fun doing a lot of times we get to in
our head we try to we're too analytical
or too data or interior to process
oriented and an easy way to step out of
its just think what do I enjoy doing
what do I have the most fun doing what
do I get lost in we all have something
that we can get lost in and nowadays
there's no stupid answers because you
could turn almost anything into a career
you know ten years ago if you said that
you wanted to be a gamer that wouldn't
have worked out you know you wouldn't be
able to make money as a professional
gamer but now a lot of professional
gamers are making more than our parents
made right if if you're a faker or if
you're a double lifts or you're in the
League of Legends scene or the other
games as well like you're making some
money and that is doable another option
if you like hanging out with your
friends if you're really people are
needed person that's a strong strength
like that may lead you to a career in HR
or a business as a speaker or business
as a as a coach or consultant with other
people so just think about before trying
to figure out how it's all gonna make
sense that's where we always get caught
up before thinking about how does this
turn into a perfect plan for myself just
think about what can I get lost in what
do I love doing if I didn't have
responsibilities or the great question
if I had all the money in the world what
would I do with my time yes you're gonna
travel yes you're gonna buy whatever
you're gonna buy all the sub great you
still have money left over yourself time
in abundance what are you gonna do
cuz you'll get sick of traveling you get
sick of buying stuff you'll need to do
something that has a little bit more
meaning to your life I promise you you
may be saying no that's not true
it's true it'll happen so what would you
do if you had that kind of money what
would you do with your time and thinking
about that then allows you to think okay
if I really like those things from there
you can pull out your strengths and
weaknesses so really making a list of
the things you can get lost in that you
just love doing that number two is think
about what you dangering about so may
not be what you're doing right now but
when you lie in bed about the pass out
or when you are you know in the shower
thinking or when you're walking through
nature going on a hike or when you're
traveling or lying on the beach or
whenever it is that you kind of get hit
with some inspiration what do you
daydream about doing maybe you're not
doing it yet but you wish you could do
it you know you have these crazy dreams
sometimes and I wish I could be doing
that or people you look up to when you
think about what you daydream about
again don't don't make it practical yet
just write down a list of things that
you wish you could be spending your time
on you wish you could be doing and then
I would try to find some small way to
actually start doing it the test to see
if you like it to see if you're good at
it a lot of times the grass is greener
on the other side a lot of times that
thing that you want to do once you start
doing it is way too much work and not
what you thought it was gonna be and you
don't want to do it anymore but
sometimes when you do it it's like I
love this I want to keep doing it so you
never know to actually get started I
never thought I'd be a salsa dancer I
never thought I would run a salsa school
and invest in by it I never thought that
part of my plan I'm tall I didn't speak
Spanish you know I take big steps I
didn't learn the music growing up it's
all on paper there's all the reasons why
it would never work out for me
as a salsa dancer but I just I loved it
and I I went to a class and want to go
back and want to do it again I want to
again say things YouTube videos my first
videos sucked
they really were bad but I liked it I
liked the process I wanted to do it
again I want to do again I wasn't
getting any results wasn't getting any
comments no views no shares nothing I
just loved it so I had to do it again
and again and again and so instead of
making it some big plan on what you want
to do with your life that can seem
overwhelming that can seem depressing
it's upsetting because you don't have
clarity I would just think about the
things that you have some daydreams
about that you
wish you could do and then find some
small way to get started just hit that
little bit of the pyramid instead of
theme is this huge project just like
this little thin wedge it's little tiny
piece to test it to say yes to one thing
you can say yes to going to try rock
climbing without having to become a
professional rock climber you could say
yes they're going on a date with one
girl to see how it works out without
having to get married to her right so
say yes try it the thing you have in
your mind find some small way to get
started and then you'll see if you enjoy
it if your strengths come out good
number three is think about what do you
do differently than others you are a
strange duck in some respects you know
you're not exactly like everybody else
you're not the same as all your the
friends you are your own unique little
snowflake and so what is it that you do
or the way that you think that is just
different than other people it's an
important question ask because a lot of
times you may not see those things as
strengths you may even see those things
as weaknesses that because you're
different you're not good like the other
people are at this other thing but you
see the world slightly differently than
other people do and where do you stand
out compared to the people around you
and just accidental question we'll pull
out some things that are very
interesting so for me I'm very mission
driven I'm also very pragmatic you know
I I don't really hang out a lot of times
just going for beer and watching movies
with friends a lot of times is the
purpose behind what I do you know
there's a purpose behind the
conversations I have I don't like
dealing with small problems I want to
look behind it to see the bigger cause
and go out and solve that big thing you
know that could be a weakness in some
social settings but it's also a strength
for me in that it allows me to build
this business allows you to build this
movement it allows me to create great
content and videos for you guys and so
just asking yourself what do I do that's
different than most people again without
thinking about how it's gonna apply
practically down the road just what do I
do that's different or what do I think
about in a different way than the people
around me I make a list and through
there you'll be able to find some of
what you might have thought were
weaknesses but could actually be
strengths for your future career
[Music]
so tip number four is be brutally honest
with yourself all of us are so unique
and we have different strengths and
weaknesses and sometimes admitting to
some of them could be really
embarrassing for us so for example I'm
an organizational disaster I don't do
well with organization at all which is
why I have to create structure around my
life I have to schedule my days to do
specific things because if I don't I'm
gonna fall off track and I'll just find
myself lying on the floor staring at the
ceilings dreaming about a brighter
future the truth is that brighter future
will never come if I don't do something
about my organization that's why I stick
to my schedule as much as possible and I
only stray away from it when there's
something urgent that needs to be taken
care of and on the other side I did not
want to admit that my strength is
empathy
especially when I started out in the
workforce and I was up against all these
alpha males and they're like oh you're
such a woman you just want to hold hands
and and hug people and feel what people
are feeling and I hid it inside of me
for a long time and I took on personas
that wasn't even mine and then
eventually I admit it to myself empathy
is not only a strength for me it's my
superpower it allows me to feel what
other people are feeling my mission is
to help people what better way to help
people that feel what they're feeling
and really understand what they're going
through I think most of us are aware of
our strengths and weaknesses the only
thing you need to do is just be brutally
honest with yourself
[Music]
number five is use your friends as
counselors but not jailers so one of the
things that we tend to do when we don't
know the answer to something is we ask
our friends and our friends can be a
great window into understanding us a
little bit better asking your friend
what you think your strengths and
weaknesses are can give you a
perspective on yourself
the thing is though you have to be
careful about it because your friends
see one side of you they see a certain
side that you know maybe one friend sees
one side and another friend sees another
side and and there's still a piece of
you two that's hidden that you haven't
shared with anybody that you just keep
to yourself that you don't want exposed
and so the positive of asking your
friends what you think your strengths
and weaknesses are is that you get some
insight into you into that side that you
are showing the negative side though is
that because they only see one aspect of
you that that becomes your jail cell
that because this is how they see you
you have to continue behaving only in
that way and go in on those strengths
and you're missing this whole of the
part that you're not sharing and so I'm
always reluctant on any of these
personal development exercises and
self-awareness because it's what it is
it's your self-awareness I'm always
reluctant to go outside and ask other
people I think your your time is better
spent with yourself like spend more time
with yourself then time with other
people if you want to understand
yourself because the answers are here
not out there but if you want to it
gives you a perspective so again use
your friends as counselors but not as
jailers you don't have to live up to
their expectations or that one side of
you and spending some good time with
yourself to reflect to write down to
spend time with nature to think about
the whole you and what you're really
good at and where you want to focus is
important
[Music]
tip number six is ask yourself what do
you hate doing often the way to find
what you're good at is by thinking about
what you're not good at so just like in
the process of your one word some people
find it easy to find their one word the
most important core value by going
positive thinking about all the good
things in their life and figuring out
what their most important core value is
some people can't get down to it only
going positive they find that better
going opposite going negative so think
about the people who you can't stand
being around what values do they have
what's just like toxic to you you can't
stand being around these kinds of people
I'm being in these kinds of situations
and by figuring out that that's your
anti word you can figure out your one
word and so think about what you hate
doing think about what other people may
like doing the people around you they
enjoy doing it but for you it's like I
can't believe people like doing that
what would you absolutely hate spending
your time on every single day and that
gets you to a list of weaknesses and the
opposite will be what you're really good
at so like what is the thing that you
absolutely hate doing and then what's
the exact opposite of that chances are
that's where you should be playing and
tip number seven is just say yes more if
you have no idea what your passion is if
you have no idea what your strengths are
your weaknesses are just say yes more
when somebody invites you to do
something don't immediately judge it and
say well this is not gonna be for me so
yes try it see if you want to go back so
if you want to do it again see if it
sparked anything we talked about not
putting so much pressure on it being the
perfect thing and making it some big
huge project and it has to work out but
also just exposing yourself to more
things exposing yourself to
opportunities that maybe your parents
wouldn't agree with or maybe it wasn't
part of your culture but it's still kind
of curious for you if something hits on
your radar say oh that's interesting or
a friend comes and tells you I want to I
want you to come out to this thing at
least try it once it's good to adopt the
mentality we have to try almost anything
you know within reason once try new
foods once try new club ones try a new
activity once try a new kind of movie
once if you've tried it and it doesn't
work out great you know you don't have
to do it again but at least trying it
once because I think most of the time we
discount so many things that we've never
even tried we're judging things we've
never even spent
any amount of time on and then you just
constantly live in this narrow lane and
that's Paul not even the best path for
you there's some pathway out here that
you don't even know you should be on
because you never bothered expanding
your horizon so if you feel lost if you
feel like you don't know what your
strengths and your weaknesses are if you
feel like you don't know what you're
passionate about then try multiple
things at least once say yes to a lot of
things and if it doesn't work great kill
it you don't have to make a lifelong
commitment to being a salsa dancer if
you go to a class you don't like it but
at least say yes once try see if it's
for you see if you want to go back
expand that reach say yes wants to
almost anything and through that process
you'll discover your passion your
strengths and your weaknesses so those
are my seven tips on how to discover
your strengths and weaknesses I'd love
to know what do you guys think what was
your favorite tip what's most relevant
to you resonated the most leave it down
in the comments below did I miss an
eight nineteen that you want to add to
the list leave in the comments I'm
really curious to find out and also if
you're commenting within the first
couple hours of this video going live
then you have a chance to win one of our
two daily prizes now I made this video
because Camille Reagan asked me to so if
there's a topic you'd like me to cover
in a future seven ways video check out
the link in the description you can go
cast your vote you can vote on other
people's topics or come up with your own
and maybe you'll get lucky and we'll
profile it soon I also want to give a
quick shot of - Hugo Baer Hugo thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and taking that picture
and sending it to me I'm curious what
you're looking at something on the
ceiling something happening up there I
want to know next time but thank you
again for posting I really appreciate
the support and I hope you enjoyed the
book thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon